andy dalton restarts his career in
chicago after a one-year stop in dallas
following his release by the bengals a
year ago
here is dalton from his introductory
press conference with the team in a city
that for the most part doesn't want him
you know you're talking as if you're the
starter what kind of what kind of
assurances have you
been given by the bears uh that they're
done at quarterback that they're not
going to be making any other moves to
bring in more competition for you
the they told me i was a starter that
was one of the reasons why i wanted to
come here and so every conversation i've
had is
has been that so
that's the assurance that i've got
oh andy you silly silly boy
you look how many times shireen have we
seen a quarterback get signed in free
agency and he's the starter they hold up
the jersey they have the press
conference and then here comes the draft
and what happens what happens
quarterback drafted in round one not oh
and you're you're still the starter
you're still the starter until you're
not until you get benched
yep you look at ryan fitzpatrick last
year right he finally got benched for
tua and it happened to tyrod taylor when
he had the injury sooner than it was
supposed to happen and justin herbert
wally pipped him and that was done for
for tyrod taylor and now he's moved on
so yeah absolutely mike he's going to go
in there as the presumed starter but
that doesn't mean he's going to start
especially with nick foles behind him
and we know nick foles history as a
backup quarterback he does really well
when he comes in for somebody else but
it's curious to me mike
that
the bears if ryan pace
and and this organization if they move
on from these guys coach and gm after
this year it's all going to go back to
the quarterback errors that they've made
and you start obviously with taking
trubisky second overall but they could
have andy dalton last year in free
agency
and they didn't do it and they went with
trubisky again and they went with traded
for nick foles and got him in as the
backup and then went ping pong back and
forth with those two guys at quarterback
but i'm not sure
based on what they did last year when
you look at the weapons that andy dalton
had in dallas
and then you look at the weapons that
mitchell trubisky had in chicago
i'm not so sure that mitchell trubisky
didn't have a better year than annie
dalton did last year his passer rating
was much better than any daltons was and
andy dalton had a ton of weapons in
dallas so i'm not sure this is an
upgrade for the bears so i understand
how bears fans are feeling right now
well and and look i
we're going to talk about trubisky in a
second but trubisky went to the playoffs
two out of three years
and and there's there's value in that
um but the problem is in 2018 when matt
nagy became the head coach
he refused to alter his system well it
was more 2019 when it hit the fan 2018
he made it work like training wheels
with trubisky and it was good enough
because the defense was really good
because vic fangio was there 2019 is
when it all started to fall apart
because that was when the square peg
round whole thing really happened
between trubisky and nagi and now this
year what we saw was negi adjusting the
offense to suit trubisky and it began to
work but dalton five straight playoff
appearances to start his career with the
bengals i i think that trubisky isn't as
bad as the bears fans thought but dalton
won't be as bad as the bears fans feel
at least the expectations are low that's
a good thing if you're the best look
you've been in the playoffs two times in
the last three years you've managed to
keep the expectations low going into
2021. that's good because if you go nine
and seven or ten and six the fans are
going to be pleasantly surprised
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports